I was adopted at Birth man I don't know
anybody from my biological side I
decided to do some searching I found my
mother on Facebook I saw some bad news
she's locked up right now up North for a
while
for quite a while I decided to message
her yesterday man I finally got the ball
as a messenger I was nervous I didn't
know how she would respond you know and
uh
she she emailed me back this morning and
it was real positive you know like
everything she had to say was real
positive and it's just
it's crazy man it's crazy you know
that's something I dreamed about my
entire life like every day
since I can remember I dreamed of being
able to talk to my mother man and uh
she's gonna give me a call this uh this
afternoon we're gonna talk on the phone
for the first time
it's crazy man it's been 32 years since
the last time I saw it you know so
I don't know exactly you know I text my
brother
my adopted brother and let him know and
then the next thing I did was I hopped
on the phone and gave you a call man I
don't you know I don't know exactly why
you know obviously we don't know each
other but
I just I wanted to share that with you
man daring brother
man thank you bro
thank you man this is uh
that's a nice that's a pat it's just
nice
you know it's nice that there's
something powerful going there's
something powerful going on in your life
and you thought and you
your nature whoever you are
you thought hey man I'm feeling
something there's really something
special going on I'm gonna share it with
somebody else not even that it was with
me with this group uh
but this is a powerful moment I'm going
to share this with somebody else
um
that's awesome man thank you for the
call uh uh you got me up in here dog you
hit me in those man
my Chisholm James is a freaking
you got me in them damn
um
my little skeet almonds these things are
activated uh
you know
it's funny man you
because you sound like you're in a good
place man this is just judgment from
this call
but you sound like you're in a good
place and
um
obviously your mother probably
isn't in the best place uh with jail
but
it sounds like you are going to be able
to be there
you may have a chance to be for your
mother what she wasn't for you
which
and and that you may be strong enough to
do that
and that is
that's on God man I think
yeah I can't imagine you know waiting
your heart to talk to your mother God
you know all those times when you don't
even realize as a child as an offspring
as a creation or something that you need
that thing to be there
and not even sometimes their voice but
even just in their presence to know that
something is there
to support you like just like a wall
but like a wall that like loves you so
matter so so much no matter what
and a wall that's really also a door
um
man
but it sounds like you you
however your life has worked out that
you
sound healthy enough where you can you
might be able to be
whatever she never had in addition to
you guys working out your mother-son
relationship
um
and that's really that's that's what
that gets amazing about life it's like
what am I supposed to
how can I be useful in this situation
and me I don't know if I could do that
because I would probably look too much
at my own plight
I'd be looking too much at all man my
mother this and I don't know if I'd be
able to turn that corner
and say honestly hey what is
why now are we back together and what
how do I look past my own
angst or my own you know or you may not
even have any more of that [__] but how
do I Rise Above That to be whatever
how do I be a great son and an adult son
you know I've had trouble evolving in
that way and evolving
from being just a son to being an an
adult son
um
that's funny this is kind of a space
that I'm in in my life but man I and I
didn't mean to talk about myself so much
it just it's powerful that you chose to
share that with us man
you know how good that makes us feel
first of all to have an urban guy call
Urban person that even [__] messes
with us bro
praise God dog
but even more than that just that
that you're like hey I I'm gonna I'm
gonna be
that you let all of us you let us enjoy
that moment with you
you let us in on that man you know how
much that is it's gonna give us
something
it's gonna give us a little bit more
faith that's going to get us through the
next day the next hour then that some
people just might be a minute but it's
going to give us something it gives me a
re if we want to believe
that there's things out there that are
working for good
that's cool man so excited for you bro
uh if you get a chance man hit the
hotline again
um I'd just love to know how it went
you know
but if you are in that space where you
say hey man this is something powerful
and I'm gonna call him a sheriff this is
I'm gonna let this be a part of this
Ambiance of this show
man that means a lot
and um yeah we'll connect and let me see
if maybe there's something if there's
something nice we could do to help out
or help her I don't know uh
but somehow
even even though it was giving you up or
what I don't know all I don't know any
of it
but shhh
she helped make a good son
you know she helped make a good sign
somehow
um
so
man
you know it this stuff I guess makes me
want to be alive
it makes me want to be alive
you know it's those moments man we use
[__] something you feel something
God that [__] is hot that is a high bro
that is a high bro
praise God baby thank you for calling in
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one